so this isn't going to be your usual
video on warming up because let's face
it warming up usually is pretty boring
it's like the vegetables of training
it's that thing you have to do at the
start of your workout before you can do
the actual fun stuff just kind of
jumping around without really much idea
of what you're supposed to be doing when
you really just want to be getting work
done warming up is just this annoying
foreplay but it doesn't have to be that
way because warming up isn't just this
thing you have to do to not get injured
it also can enhance your performance
significantly and if you do it correctly
warming up actually has benefits all its
own as well it can actually work as part
of your training what we really need to
do here is to properly understand the
science of warming up what is it that
we're actually achieving what are we
doing when we're warming up and how can
we make sure we do that quickly
efficiently and in a way that's going to
massively benefit our training well
that's what we're going to find out in a
minute but before we get started first
and add admission because when I was
younger I used to not warm up at all in
fact I used to say that warming up was
for wimps which yeah it's a bit cringe
to here now but what I do is I go
straight to the gym and start performing
my max bench press which was like two
times body weight at the time and I'd be
doing pull-ups and muscle ups completely
from cold and whilst I don't recommend
it and whilst I learned pretty quickly
that this isn't something that everyone
should be doing it was interesting that
I never got injured from this there's a
few reasons that might have been the
case including individual differences
and I think by understanding these
things we can better understand how to
perform our warm-ups optimally and avoid
injury and enhance performance
something you might be wondering
reasonably is do you actually need to
warm up when you warm up as in is it
important to raise your body temperature
is this a key part of the process and
the answer is actually yes warming up
has a number of beneficial effects on
the body for one heating up muscle and
tendon actually makes it more pliable
much like heating any viscous material
like honey for another it also actually
increases nerve conduction velocity
meaning that you can transmit signals
more rapidly and potentially increase
your reflexes and on top of all that it
also helps with the number of enzymatic
reactions that support muscle
contraction things like the breakdown of
glucose and glycogen so yeah actually
heating up is important it's not just a
clever name
mmm cheesy at the same time warming up
and moving the joint gently really does
lubricate the joints this isn't just a
metaphor As you move around gently this
stretches The Joint capsule and that
stimulates the synovial membrane to
squeeze out more synovial fluid and to
ramp up production at the same time as
you increase the heat around the area
this actually makes that fluid more
viscous so that it does its job a little
bit better isn't quite so sticky and
tire-like but while that stuff's
important I think it's increasing blood
flow to the muscles that's really going
to make the difference in terms of your
performance how do you do sir
so jumping rope or another form of light
aerobic exercise is a great way to start
your warm-up and there's a few reasons
for that of course initially we're
opening up the lungs the Airways
increasing the heart rate this is
allowing us to get more blood and oxygen
around the body but specifically we're
also increasing our production of
adrenaline and this is important because
adrenaline
prepares the body for fight or flight or
in this case exercise
so one of the reasons that I might have
been able to get away with doing less of
a warm-up in my youth is that I actually
have high resting levels of adrenaline
as I've mentioned on this channel before
and that means that blood goes more
quickly more readily to the muscles
where it's needed because adrenaline
increases your heart rate it triggers a
Cascade of other excitatory
neurotransmitters but at the same time
it also acts on certain receptors which
alter the way that blood flows around
the body specifically the a adrenergic
and B2 adrenergic receptors
so these receptors trigger contractions
in the blood vessels causing them to
become narrower or wider the a
adrenergic receptors are found
throughout the body and when adrenaline
acts on these it causes your blood
vessels to contract to restrict
themselves so they get smaller however
though when adrenaline acts on the B2
adrenergic receptors which are found
more specifically in skeletal muscle
tissue this causes them to dilate to get
larger this means you're creating a
pressure differential so that the blood
vessels that supply blood to your organs
and other parts of your body your
digestion stuff like that are getting
narrower making it harder for blood to
get in and the blood vessels supplying
the muscles are getting wider and more
relaxed allowing more blood to get in
it's being squeezed to the muscles
therefore meaning you have more oxygen
more blood more nutrients to perform
optimally as a result of Performing this
kind of exercise and increasing your
adrenaline there are many different
forms of aerobic training you can use to
achieve this I personally really like
jump rope as one of my go-to options
that's not only because it's a full body
exercise meaning you get more blood
around the entire body and more quickly
but also because it's something that has
many other benefits as well it's it's a
skill that you can develop it makes you
lighter on your feet it builds ankle
stiffness for things like sprinting and
jumping it's just an excellent exercise
Even build stronger calves that brings
me to today's sponsor which is crossroad
Crossroad make some of the best jump
ropes in the business they use
proprietary materials on their ropes so
they don't get tangled so they don't get
damaged over time they seem to last
forever they have advanced spin
mechanics in the handles themselves
which make them spin more smoothly
they're really easy to attach and detach
meaning that you can swap out different
handles different ropes and the reason
you might want to do this is because
Crossroad also make a range of different
weighted ropes this one's five pounds I
think and basically that means that I'm
getting a slight shoulder workout at the
same time as training my lower body
whichever one you choose use the link
down below and code bioneer at checkout
to get 15 off your first order thanks
again to Crossroad for sponsoring this
video and now on with the show
now as many of you guys know I've been
training for a long time with very high
repetition sets of basic body weight
movements close chain movements like the
push-up the S squat the chin up and I
believe this could have played a role in
my ability to train without a long
warm-up as well
basically what this does is to increase
blood supply to the muscles by pooling
blood as you're training there's no
direct studies demonstrating this but
you can follow the bread Trail and see
how they might be connected and I've
made lots of videos discussing this in
the past suffice to say that by keeping
the focus on specific muscle groups you
make it harder for the blood to get in
and out and your body responds by
creating more blood supply to those
muscles then if you combine this with
high adrenaline you might not only have
a greater propensity to push blood
towards the muscles but also more
inroads more ways to supply the muscles
so whilst this is purely hypothetical
what I'm saying is that potentially by
training with higher repetition basic
movements focusing on specific muscles
you may be able to reduce the time it
takes you to warm up for training and
other full body aerobic exercises like
running also increase full body
angiogenesis and there are studies
demonstrating this so this might also
help you to perform more quickly to get
the most out of your body when there
isn't time to warm up because in the
real world there isn't always time to
warm up
of course there's lots of other ways we
can increase adrenaline such as drinking
caffeine which will increase adrenaline
raise your heart rate essentially it's
like a warm up in a cup this is why
pre-workouts contain huge amounts of
caffeine it has been shown definitively
to improve performance in the gym
and then this is combined with things
like beta alanine which act as
vasodilators to further help dilate the
blood vessels and help blood get flowing
to the muscles in theory I personally am
not the biggest fan of using things like
caffeine as a pre-workout because it
just lacks Nuance you're just hijacking
your system and ramping it up because
when you're training your muscles
release byproducts which have all kinds
of different impacts on the way your
body works for example adenosine gets
released as a byproduct of exercise and
this is another vasodilator it gets more
blood flowing to the muscles but
caffeine blocks the adenosine receptors
meaning that you're not going to get as
much oxygen and blood to the muscles
specifically although you have a global
increase in vasodilation if you're
taking a pre-workout you might find that
you have a little bit extra constriction
in the working muscles I'm just saying
it lacks Nuance it's not as delicate as
the body's own processes for increasing
adrenaline and just jacking something up
to try and get the most performance I
don't think is necessarily always the
best idea not to mention that caffeine
can cause anxiety it makes the muscles
tensor which can actually inhibit
performance particularly if you're doing
a Mobility routine so it kind of depends
on your goals and your own reaction to
caffeine I'm just saying personally I
don't know it's a bit artificial
in other words I think something like
this
pretty much useless
[Music]
of course there are many other ways you
can increase adrenaline and boost your
heart rate one of my very favorite is
just to listen to awesome music we know
intuitively that this increases
adrenaline but that's also true
according to these studies this is a
great way to get yourself hyped for a
workout to prime your mood and actually
the studies show that the best way to do
this is to create a playlist that starts
with a slower Tempo and then builds up
gradually over time and this is a great
way to increase our own tempo as it were
in keeping rather than just going
straight from cold and depressed to
suddenly massive drums and rock and you
can throw me to the world
so don't lean into that bad mood try
putting on some decent music bouncing
around your kitchen and you might just
bring yourself to do that workout after
all
[Music]
another way to increase adrenaline and
get yourself pumped for workout without
relying on caffeine or other chemicals
is by watching something that gets you
pumped so for me that might be a Jackie
Chan Montage or a clip from Dragon Ball
Z something like that in fact the other
day I was feeling a bit burned out and
wasn't really in the mood to train at
all I think I was recovering from some
kind of injury and some kind of bug and
hadn't had much sleep because my son had
been keeping me awake all night and I
was in a kind of bad mood and I was
meant to be working out but I'd kind of
already decided I wasn't going to do it
that day but then I was scrolling
YouTube and I just went outtakes Montage
from the new Jackie Chan film ride on
and so I watched it and it had him
singing in the background which made me
kind of nostalgic because although this
was a new song it just reminded me of
the old tracks he used to record for his
movie so I loved growing up I think in
one scene he fell off a horse and he
just break falls and gets up just fine
age 69 this guy's one of my heroes
growing up and it was just so inspiring
seeing this not only getting me pumped
by watching you know clips of fighting
but also just seeing one of my heroes
still moving at this age was so
inspiring that I thought you know what
I'm gonna hit the gym and had a really
good workout
so now we've done our full body aerobic
exercise to warm up we've got blood
flowing around the body a little bit
more than we did before now we want to
focus on getting that blood specifically
to the muscle groups we're going to be
using so to do this we want to train
with something that's a bit more
isolated that focuses on a particular
muscle group
this then sends the blood even more to
those muscles that we're using it does
this in a couple of ways firstly some of
the byproducts released as a result of
using the muscle will further dilate the
blood vessels in those muscles thus
helping the blood to flow in that
direction
at the same time though the muscles also
now actually working like some kind of
pump so as the muscle contracts it
squeezes the blood out of the blood
vessels and then when it relaxes again
the blood is able to fill back in this
ensures a nice turnover of fresh blood
keeping it pumping and flowing into
those working muscles so how do we do
this well we can use a few simple
exercises things like knee circles arm
windmills that kind of thing that's
going to get the blood flowing to the
area we want and nicely lubricate the
joints
but better yet is to use warm-up sets or
to use activation exercises
so warm-up set basically involves doing
the exercise you're going to do for your
workout but you're doing it with either
no weight at all or very very
lightweight so for example if you're
going to be doing heavy squats then for
your warm-up set you'll just squat with
a really light barbell this way you're
able to practice the movement and
activate the muscles
similarly an activation exercise is
basically an exercise designed to
specifically teach you remind you how to
move correctly and to get the correct
muscles working and engaged get yourself
feeling those muscles so that when you
then perform the movements that follow
you're able to do so properly so for
example here you might perform something
like a glute Bridge prior to doing your
squats and that way you're ensuring that
you're engaging the glutes and not quad
dominant for example
both of these will have the effect of
sending more blood to those specific
muscle groups but at the same time it'll
also allow you to rehearse the movements
and make sure that you're using the
correct movement pattern
isn't just a convenient way a nice way
to practice the movement actually goes a
bit deeper than that and there's some
interesting science showing how using
activation exercises and warm-up sets
allows you to recruit more muscle fiber
so that you can exert more power and
force and wake up the signals to and
from the muscles increasing your
proprioception your balance your body
awareness and more which we'll talk
about when we get to my office
I don't know if feeling like this is
safe I mean I talk to friends in the car
so presumably it's not that much
different from that and I've seen other
YouTubers do it but I think I'm gonna
make this a one-off because my
multitasking
isn't always my strong seat
so I do recommend you do some general
movement in the areas that you're going
to train things like your knee circles
and your windmills because this can
actually help to lubricate the joints
and get them moving make them more
pliable reduce your chance of injury
beyond that though the warm-up sets and
the activation exercises are also really
important and there's a few reasons for
this firstly it's going to help you to
establish more of a mind muscle
connection now before you accuse me of
Bro Science here think about how many of
us will train we'll spend our whole day
sitting at a desk on our butts squishing
our glutes in this awkward tight posture
then we go to the gym and start lifting
really heavy weights just doing a little
bit of aerobic exercise for your warm-up
isn't going to cut it you've basically
crushed the life out of your butt and
forgotten how to use it you've forgotten
how to move properly and now you're far
more likely to move incorrectly and
cause an injury so I start every workout
now with glute bridges for example to
really feel my glutes and to remind
myself how to hinge the hip properly so
that when I'm doing a deadlift or
something like that I'm not going to
injure myself so practicing in this way
either with exercises designed to engage
the muscles in the correct way or with
your warm-up sets can help you to send a
stronger signal subsequently to those
muscles and to inhibit the surrounding
muscles so you're doing it properly for
example this can help us to reduce
inhibitory signals so over time if we're
not using a muscle at all we can
actually begin to inhibit it and not
feel it in the same way so imagine if
there's a clock in the background of a
room when you first walk in you notice
it ticking loudly but over time you
forget it's there completely because
you're actually inhibiting that
tick-tocking sound at the same time this
can help to combat what's called
synergistic dominance which is where
you're allowing the synergistic muscles
the supporting muscles to do most of the
work that should be done by the prime
mover again the obvious example here is
someone who's quad dominant and who's
using their quads to perform movements
like jumps when they really should be
engaging glutes more fundamentally what
we're doing here is priming the neural
Pathways and the muscles for Activation
when you perform a certain movement it
becomes easier to perform it
subsequently for a little bit and this
is called post activation potentiation
essentially when certain neurons fire in
the brain responsible for movement they
don't return to the same resting state
they return to a slightly higher resting
state making it easier to then trigger
another action potential what you
basically need to know is that they
remain warmed up effectively so that
they can start again more easily thus it
becomes easier for the same neural
Pathways to fire generating more
efficient movement patterns this is why
contrast training works this is why if
you do a really heavy squat you're then
going to be able to jump really high
onto a box afterwards and it's why you
feel all bouncy when you come off of a
trampoline but of course this doesn't
last that long it lasts 30 to 60 seconds
so if you want to get the benefits of
contrast training post activation
potentiation you need to go straight
from your heavy reps straight into
jumping onto that box we don't just have
post activation potentiation we also
have a post activation performance
enhancement and this lasts longer it's
saying that even though the resting
state of the neurons return to a lower
State eventually we retain a little bit
of enhanced performance for much longer
up to 30 minutes or even beyond that
this is due to some of the warming up
facts as we talked about already The
increased heart rate adrenaline blood
flow to the muscles Etc but it's also
still due to some changes within the
neurons thanks to something called
dynamical synapses or short-term
plasticity
so for example and I won't go into this
in too much detail because you don't
need to know it and I did make a video
on this already if you want that then
check out my video on priming but for
example short-term synaptic facilitation
is another process through which neurons
become more likely to fire that's
because the action potentials aren't
just about electrical charges when a
neuron fires it also releases
neurotransmitters which alter the way
that it interacts with the neurons
around it after neurotransmitters have
been released from the vesicles it
becomes subsequently easier if those
neurotransmitters to be released again
thanks to changes in the calcium ion
concentration vesicles being like little
containers which hold on to the
neurotransmitters at the end of the
presynaptic neurons essentially this
means that neural Pathways will fire
more easily when they've already fired
before or at least it will alter the way
they fire so when you perform these
movements you're priming and readying
the Brain to perform them again
now of course if you haven't just been
sat still all day but you've been active
and moving throughout the day if you've
been walking and stretching been using
your body then you might find you're not
as seized up as someone who has sat in
one place all day and this is something
else to consider is that if you're more
active and if you make a effort to be
more active throughout the day then
you're not going to need to warm up for
as long as somebody who has just been
sat in one position you could even
really make the argument that we
shouldn't have to warm up much at all if
you think about your dog for example if
they see a bird or a squirrel on the
other side of the road they're not going
to stop and do lunges in these circles
they're just going to blast across
without giving it a second thought
they're ready to spring into action at
any time after a long nap they might do
something called a penticulation this is
kind of like that big stretchy yawn they
do this helps you activate and engage
the muscles and improve proprioception
but that's all they really need to do it
is also worth noting that you can't even
use a kind of mindfulness meditation a
body scan meditation to focus on
relaxing and Contracting the muscles and
that way too reawaken your mind muscle
connection
another useful function of a good
warm-up is to act as a kind of
diagnostics test to see how your body's
performing for example I was just at the
gym and I was going to do some handstand
push-ups but I discovered that my elbow
is a little bit Dicky and I wasn't aware
of that so instead of going hard I
decided to go easy and cut my workout
short this way I avoid a minor niggle
becoming a serious injury by going too
hard and this is actually yet another
reason you don't want too much
adrenaline because it is a natural
painkiller and it can blunt your sensor
to these sorts of things have you ever
considered that if you're unable to ramp
your body up to its fullest naturally
then maybe that's a sign that you
shouldn't be training hard not that you
should take artificial products to try
and jack it up anyway listen to your
body
and that brings us on to the
controversial topic of stretching and it
might seem mad that stretching as part
of a warm-up could be controversial but
if you guys are interested in this stuff
then you already know the story by now
there was a time that stretching static
stretches holding a static stretch often
a passive stretch forcing yourself into
a greater range of motion than you can
achieve comfortably on your own was the
norm for a warm-up however over time
studies came out showing that this could
actually increase our risk of injury and
reduce our performance and this makes
sense because if you're carrying a
little bit of tension in the muscle if
it's shorter then it's going to be
easier for it to quickly contract on the
other hand if it's loose and relaxed
then this is actually going to make it a
little bit less efficient to quickly
Contracting to say for example catch you
if you're falling or slow down a
movement and preventing a hyper
extension
so suddenly nobody likes doing static
stretches and passive stretches as part
of their warm-up they might do dynamic
stretches things like high kicks Etc but
they're going to avoid anything like
pancake stretches or straddle stretches
shoulder stretches prior to their
workout and yeah this makes sense but I
just think we need to be a little bit
cautious about potentially throwing the
proverbial baby out with the bath water
here but we act like this is this
terrible thing that if you do a little
bit of passive stretching you're
definitely going to injure yourself but
but Jesse Santana points out to me that
most athletes still do this kind of
stretching prior to a game in the
changing room it's pretty normal and
when you think about it we were doing
this kind of stretching prior to
training for years decades before anyone
noticed there was anything wrong with it
so it kind of been that bad for us and
maybe it's a bit of an extreme reaction
to treat it like this kind of kryptonite
that's going to cause us harm not only
that but depending on the type of
stretch depending on what part of your
body you're stretching depending on the
type of workout you're doing it may
still have some benefit
for example what if you were to stretch
only the antagonist muscles if you had a
very specific workout in mind and you
stretched only antagonistic muscles this
could actually increase your performance
because now to have less resistance
provided by those antagonistic muscles
you could jump higher punch harder run
faster you would also potentially be
increasing your likelihood of injury
however because now you've got less of
the antagonistic muscle to slow down and
control the movement so you know pros
and cons what shows even more promise
though is performing stretches that have
a strength component Mobility exercises
rather than pure flexibility exercises
where you're putting yourself in that
position often against resistance things
like the atg split squat or something
like a very deep squat holding a weight
this has been shown to actually improve
power output and potentially reduce your
chance of injury because you're
increasing your strength in those end
range positions you're still getting
into those deep stretches but you're
doing so in a way that's actually going
to enhance your performance by giving
you more control and strength and power
in those positions and I personally will
even use some static passive stretches
when I want to perform a particular
movement so for example if I'm doing
handstands then stretching my shoulders
will allow me to do better handstands
whatever the studies say this is the
reality for me and I don't think it's
very likely that it's going to increase
my likelihood of injury all that much it
does depend a lot on how stiff you are
to begin with if you're very restricted
in terms of movement then a little bit
of extra Mobility might be just what you
need
this section is not about giving you
concrete advice I'm not here to tell you
that you should ignore all this recent
research and everyone telling you not to
passive stretch before a workout all I
want to say is that this topic is a bit
more complex than some people would have
you believe I think the jury is still
out I think it's very much about
individual differences and different
scenarios so do your own research Go
Gentle but yeah definitely watch this
space
so if we're going to take all of this
Theory and all these ideas and create a
kind of warm-up plan that anyone can
apply obviously it's going to be
different depending on who you are and
depending on what kind of workout you're
about to do that said you could start by
watching something or listening to some
music that's going to get you pumped and
prime your mood at the same time you
should be doing some sort of aerobic
exercise such as jumping rope something
full body to get the heart rate flowing
and increase adrenaline this should last
about five to ten minutes until you
reach about 50 to 75 of your max heart
rate but don't go too intense because
you'll want to tie yourself out for
later then you're going to move on to
something a little bit more localized so
whether that's knee circles arm
windmills this is going to help to
lubricate the joints it's going to help
get blood flowing in that area and
improve your general movement then you
might want to move on to either warm-up
sets or activation exercises to prepare
yourself for the movement and make sure
you're moving through it correctly
whether or not you include stretches
there it was up to you like I say this
is an area for further research and it's
going to depend on you and your goals
and how you respond to it but yeah
that's it so a warm-up can be something
pretty short really depending on who you
are and your goals it could take no more
than 10 to 15 minutes you might still
think of it as a nuisance but I think
the way to think about it is as a part
of your workout not something you have
to do prior to your workout you could
even say this is more important than the
workout that follows because what good
is it being able to bench press a huge
amount of weight if you can't squat down
to the ground or bend over to tie up
your shoelace so yeah don't see your
warm-ups as a waste of time see them as
part of your training well guys that's
pretty in-depth but hopefully useful let
me know if there's anything I missed let
me know in the comments down below how
you warm up and if you're looking for a
training program that trains you in a
way that goes beyond just Aesthetics or
just strength on a few lifts something
that's going to improve your strength
Mobility cardio brain function even
proprioception and check out the link to
my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 comes with over
two hours of instructional footage and
an 80 plus page ebook that also comes
with a full warm-up that you can follow
along with and that includes all of
these Concepts and more and that you can
adapt as you need to thanks again to
crossrate for sponsoring this video and
either way guys thanks so much for
watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now
foreign